con palos y fuegos artificiales así
respondió un sector de los docentes de
la confederación de maestros urbanos de
Bolivia a la actuación de las
autoridades
no pasa está fuerte el dolor la
explosión ha sido dentro de mi brazo un
petardo un artefacto explosivo
s de presión solo gases es un gobierno
incapaz los docentes se mantienen en las
calles desde el pasado 6 de marzo para
rechazar un nuevo plan de estudios que
entre otras cosas propone más materias a
su juicio sin la asignación previa de
más recursos
lo fundamental que plantea es más
presupuesto para la educación ya no se
puede permitir que se incorporen nuevas
asignaturas como inglés artes plásticas
computación lengua originaria sin que
tenga su cargo horaria su presupuesto el
gobierno ha rechazado la acusación de un
cambio en el plan de estudios y defiende
la actualización de contenidos tras
consultar a más de 75 organizaciones de
todo el país durante algunos meses del
año 2022
el gobierno cumplió con el incremento de
recursos para la educación y sigue
trabajando de manera conjunta para
mejorar la calidad educativa por lo que
demuestra que los dirigentes del
magisterio urbano solo buscan conflictos
no diálogo
desde el gobierno confían en que a
través del diálogo se logre el consenso
necesario para lo que aseguran será el
bienestar de la población estudiantil